- Last night I got contacted by
Nebraska, Baylor, Georgia, Memphis, Duke,
Ohio State, Alabama, UConn and Pittsburgh.
We here.
This is Terrence Clarke.
We're at the NBPA Camp in Virginia.
About to get lit, man.
It's gonna be a great setting.
Tune in right now.
When I was nine or 10 years old,
I definitely didn't see this.
I never had the vision of, you know,
being who I am now.
And, you know, that's why everyday
I just get in the gym and work because
when I was younger I never thought
this would ever happen to me.
I was playin' basketball for fun
back home in Boston.
You know, we was one of the best teams
in New England. We didn't lose a game
for two years straight, and then in fifth grade
we actually went out to Atlantic City to play
basketball against more competition, and
we lost to Team Takeover by, I think, 35-plus.
That's when I really cried, sat there
and said, "You know what? I want to
take this serious."
Aye, let's go!
You can throw it up, Noah.
You can throw it up Noah. You can throw it up.
By himself, by himself, by himself.
For college coaches to be at my game
I try not to pay attention to it too much,
you know, cuz they're right there,
and they're obviously looking at my every move,
so I just try to be on my best behavior.
I felt a lot of pressure when I was, like, first
going through this stuff, but now that
I've been playing in front of them a lot more
it's just more, you know, just playin'.
Like, I just have fun.
This is the game that I love, and
I've been playin' since I was in fifth grade, so
you know, I just want to show that
I'm a great player, obviously versatile
and have skills to, like, you know,
play at the next level.
I gotta reply to this college. Yo.
Yo, bro. Would this be–is this messed up
if I just send that back to that?
- No.
- All right.
Basketball, of course, is a bigger part in our lives,
but, you know, stuff that's off the court,
you know, we're gonna be 18, 19 years old
and, like, life gets real so, you know,
learnin' the stuff off the court from those guys
that's already been in the NBA or
guys that's been through it.
It's just, you know, it's mindful, and
it helps us, you know, when we get older.
- You did four perfect possessions
by not rushing.
You came off the pick,
you did what you had to do,
but why'd you rush the fifth one?
C'mon, don't rush it.
When you go off the screen, that's rushing.
Pull that thing back, OK?
And you come off that screen, bam. OK?
- With Ricky Davis being on me as hard as he is,
it just shows me that, you know, I have a chance.
Definitely expects a lot out of me.
Like, he's been in the NBA, you know,
with him givin' out tips and
stuff like that, tryin' to be helpful,
you know, it's great.
- You know, nowadays the generations has changed,
so you can't be all crazy and hard like I grew up
back in the day, you know, coaches is just
ridin' you the whole practice. So, you know,
you hit 'em here, you hit 'em there.
Get 'em with some good teaching points and,
you know, just watch his growth.
You see how you got that steal?
- Yeah.
- That's that energy right there.
Now you could be–you could be the best–
you could be the best n---a in this motherf--ker,
but you gotta lead by example.
They followin' you.
They say, "Well Terrence ain't playin' D,
he shootin' all the shots."
But, you turn it on n---a you could be amazing.
C'mon.
- I think Ricky just wanted me to play defense a lot,
so I think I'm just gonna add that to my game, really,
cuz if I don't play defense
he gonna yell at me, like, a million times, so.
Just playin' both sides of the court, you know,
just me gettin' steals and stuff like that.
That'll lead to runouts and, you know,
just gettin' layups or, you know,
findin' somebody else for easy buckets, so–
like, two to three steals or, you know,
defensive stops and get a defensive rebound.
- He's one of the best players in the camp, so
he has to always be ready, always be 100 percent,
120 percent, that's what the coaches are lookin' for.
- Get back White, get back White.
It's our ball, it's our ball.
He missed it, I knew it, I knew it.
I knew he was gonna miss. He missed again.
I knew it, I knew it, I knew it. Let's go, son.
Go!
The camp environment, I feel like it is
better to showcase your skills.
Especially with me tryin' to be a point guard,
I wanna bring the ball up, you know,
come off screens and stuff like that.
Find the other guy.
I think I could play the role, you know,
if you gave me the ball, I think I definitely
could do it. You know, I think
I could pass it. I could score it.
I think I could show a lot of people that
I could play, like, 1, 2 or 3.
Yeah, I'm a national champion, so
I know how you feel.
- National champion?
- National.
- How? Y'all ain't played nobody.
- NEPSAC. NEPSAC national champions.
- NEPSAC? Who's in NEPSAC?
- Yo, yo, oh so he GEICO so he's–
- Y'all ain't played nobody neither.
- These bums.
- That's a tournament.
- GEICO Nationals. Right, exactly.
- That's not the national championship.
Y'all are a tournament champion.
- So we're tournament champions?
- Y'all won–like, that's the ACC championship.
Y'all won that, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's just like that.
- So we played everybody.
- In y'all conference.
- No you didn't. Y'all didn't play us.
- Y'all didn't play them.
Walkin' out of NBPA I think
everybody can say that they learned somethin'.
You know, just to take with them.
With this summer comin' up,
I think, you know, just tryin' to work on
every part of my game.
You know, my jump shot, my handle.
Everything I can do on the court, you know,
it's gonna benefit me, so I try
to work on everything this summer.
After camp, I think I'm just gonna be
workin' out a lot.
Gettin' ready for Peach Jam, July 10th.
But, after that, I'll just be workin' out
and stuff like that.
Probably gettin' ready for Steph Curry Camp
and try to get into skills as much as I can.
Noah.
The main goal is to make it to the NBA, so
Michael Porter and Trae Young, or, like,
guys like Collin Sexton and those guys.
I always look up to them and
was, like, you know,
I want to be like them one day,
you know, like, top prospect in the country,
like I am now.
God-willingly, I make it to the NBA, and
I just want to take care of everybody
that's been through this journey.